there's a game
that i've um
been
that i've been privy to some of their
conversations where they were able to
essentially get funding for the majority
of the title
before talking to publisher so they're
basically you know the conversation
would be more like finishing funds or
um marketing support more than just
financing which it's amazing how much
that changes the dynamic
versus like
our game
is dead in the water from day one
without a publisher's um backup
wait are you saying there's a lot of
different shapes which is more standard
i would have thought that dead in the
water without a publisher would be more
normal
i think so it's also especially if it's
remotely uh you know
decent team size and has like
heavy costs associated
it can be weird in the a because games
can be very cheap to make like so a lot
of indie games obviously don't cost much
money to actually do the development and
a team can either sell fund itself or
just kind of they have day jobs or
whatever right like a lot of the smaller
stuff just starting out but then the
flip side of that as well is
if your games are hit then you have a
lot of money flowing to your company
accounts and maybe you don't need money
for the next game but you do want the
marketing support or a platform holder
would prefer it if you had a publisher
or you know you want to do xyz there's
there's there's lots of other reasons
for a more established indie to work
with the publisher than just the money
the money's
money's boring like money is money money
something you need but in a lot of
situations you don't need it either
because you're making something small
enough that you don't need it or you
know you've done well enough with
previous games that you've got a little
bit of budget what would you consider to
be a cheap game
what does that mean
it's entirely relative right like i
don't know the budget of
sms's games i have no concept but
hundreds of millions like i have no idea
it's a lot of money like but i have no
what is that sms would be like 100
million i would think so
you're not going to tell me that but
that's an expensive project yes but then
what would be that
cheap but still possible
it really like that's it's fundament i'm
not being difficult like it
fundamentally
like it's it's there's weird so there's
banding so the the easiest way to answer
your question is there's banding um
which kind of is kind of often unspoken
among developers and publishers but
you've basically got kind of
you've got and like zero to a hundred
grand and i'm going to use dollars i
think for now just because that's easier
so a hundred so zero to a hundred
thousand dollars is like your small
that's a small
uh
probably they're working from home maybe
it's a small group of people a couple of
contractors at the higher end of that
they're doing their thing right they're
in that kind of zone or uh or you know
we've made games in that price range
that the like the little smaller
projects we do between the bigger ones
right those those that's one range
then 100 to 500 is usually the kind of
range of indie game where you're
thinking of where you've got kind of an
indie publisher so 100 to 500 would be
where i would guess a lot of like you
know devolver games exist or that's
where yeah 17 games
annapurna is like
the upper end of that and probably
higher oh really so then you get i would
guess so i don't know those but i can
tell you
i don't have access to numbers but
there's no chance in hell that pathless
was made for five hundred thousand
dollars
it's nice and so part of this exists in
a really interesting space because
you've got basically then above the 500
grand mark you've got kind of five five
five so half a million to about two
three million which is the kind of space
that like
uh i don't know like more established in
the center work that's the kind of price
price range that you know i occupy maybe
a bit more but like that kind of general
area pathless would have been my guess
with no knowledge of the process
would be pathless was probably edging up
to like four or five
maybe maybe even more actually in
fairness i know that journey cost about
seven uh
so journey was unique because that's a
sony project so there would have been
lots more money bouncing around on
journey than you would see on journey is
indian an artistic sense and in a
creative situation published the
budget's period it's a published game uh
but what's interesting is it's true but
with journey what's interesting is then
off so that number may not be accurate i
just feel like i remember that from a
gdc talk no i would buy that like i
would 100 buy that like and to be honest
pathless probably goes above where i'm
at what's interesting in the indie space
is at the kind of four four million ish
to about
used to be 10 million is probably now
aging towards 15 million there's not
it's really hard to get funding in that
range because that's the range where
you're spending so much money that
obviously it's a big investment but
probably you're not hitting a quality
bar where the publisher is going to see
the return on that investment right
you're not you're not going to blow
people away with your visuals 15 million
you can't compete with a hundred million
the way that that's where and then we
get out
exactly exactly half a million you'll
see a return on if it's a great game 15
million or sorry let's put it in the
middle like eight nine million the kind
of the kind of journey range from what
you're saying austin that's a tricky one
if you if you're only works just the
game is so short also that's that
they're able to go fidelity for a very
small experience and you can mobilize
the entire sony process for that and
also crucially that's a team and you
know yourself included who have a
massive amount of respect going in so
you know you also have ancillary
products they know they're going to be
able to sell the record they know
they're going to have merchandising like
it's that kind of thing so yeah that's a
really interesting thing with the indie
space where once you go
kind of 5 million plus to about 10 to 15
that's kind of a no man's land in the
indie space there are games they're made
in that space but it's much less
populated and then on the other side of
that you start to get into the double a
and it's the same in movies where you
know it just goes up to ridiculous like
the 5 million to 10 million
movies where you have like jordan peele
um and then but there used to be the
bread and butter in the 90s you know you
think of like
you know a standard like steven seagal
action movie or a julia roberts romantic
comedy or so those all averaged 35 40
million 50
you know if it was like a special movie
and then those rare
you know titanic or
jurassic park or but even jurassic park
was like probably barely a hundred
million for its time
where they were way above the average
but the meat and potatoes of the
industry was that and over time it's
become that's the highest risk category
by far right because you're either
category well it's the middle the thing
it's the
you're going to make an investment
invest like 10 or 100 million because
both of those you're going to see a
great return on your investment yes
no guarantee you're taking the middle
doesn't make sense like it's i didn't
this is something that just you know
normal people like us who like thinking
like the kinds of numbers we think of in
our day-to-day lives
i still don't when you tell me
something's five million my brain can't
even process what that means yeah these
numbers don't make any sense to human
minds right now but that's my point is
like for us it's like no i'm gonna and
this is and this this causes so many
issues across the world but when we
think about money and saving and putting
work in and all of this stuff
actually it's just much easier to rock
up with a big bag of money that's where
the investment side of it comes in is
yeah it doesn't make sense to invest it
doesn't take make sense to invest 30
million in a movie that's going to be a
romantic comedy that might hit or miss
when you can put 100 million into
something that you know you can throw
marketing behind it's kind of too big to
fail
and you'll get a return and even if you
don't
screw it you you make two of those
instead of six of the 30 million and
you're still gonna have a hit and the
the highest hit a romantic comedy can
achieve is still lower than the highest
hit your big franchise blockbuster can
hit so it's yeah it's it's a weird
there's a weird kind of empty space in
the middle um and that's where
and it's true i mean if
literally just think about it now like
think about indie games that you have
been massively impressed by
chances are those indie games are either
made for nothing basically or a very
small number
or they are in the kind of three to five
million range in most cases so um and
i'd say the ones that make more money
are probably at the lower end yeah like
dead cells
yeah yeah yeah a couple of things one
troy we basically just started this
conversation and just stream rolled
right into it we haven't missed anything
we just arrived here real fast two
minutes baby try your hair is fantastic
man your hair looks great
for a few weeks and i come in it's like
you guys are having a real conversation
i wanted to come and be like this just
had a protein shake and my tummy feels
weird like that's the sensibility i'm
bringing to this conversation second i
was gonna ask when we talk about how
much video games cost
is the bulk of that salaries
when you talk about this like when they
talk about gta costs this much to make
is that largely paying people or is it
also marketing like i don't actually
know what that
is there's so generally it's like so
it's all going to try a lot like movie
it's all going to troy yeah if you've
got troy in your game like 50 of your
body not all of it
he must have an espresso in every room
that's right and he doesn't drink them
he just likes the smell did i tell you
he's abigail breslin
so true story i'll throw myself under
the bus
uh
i we shot this thing and uh the the
craft services is is first of all the
fact that they even have craft services
in a post code world and and the fact
that we've been able to find a way to
keep this machine moving is is is no
small feat and um
i truly appreciate everyone that's on
the crew however
the coffee on this particular shoot was
[ __ ]
and
i don't ask for much but i would like to
have a good cup of coffee in the in the
first part of the morning you're
definitely coming across as the hero of
this story already
it's going great
here's here's what i did i i ended up
going and i i got an espresso machine
and they were kind enough to provide a
room for me on set and so i i kept that
tucked in there so i would go in there
and then
for all my co-stars i was like i would
come in and i i love hosting it's like
one of the things that i love to do and
so i'd come on set and they'd be like oh
thank you so much i would make everybody
coffee
um
i just that's it again it's this is my
but that's where the like gta hitting
you know 100 million or 200 million
dollars
especially
an espresso machine for the game that
i'm absolutely not in i've never done
any of them
so are you what was the question you
asked the question was salaries yeah
what
grand theft auto cost 500 million
dollars to make what is that cost
what is it so it's a lot like the it's
like the film industry to the extent
that most of most of the time when you
hear a number thrown around it's
referring specifically to the cost of
the development of the game not the
marketing so it's that classic thing i'm
asking it because like with film at
least i understand that they have to
like wrench it
like
like you know videos yeah video games
are fake we're making all of it all of
it is made up of still have to make that
[ __ ] though
associated with it right
yes it's mostly salaries thank you is
that true you're welcome well i i feel
like you may be accidentally revealing
that you're not actually being paid and
i feel like you ought to i feel like you
ought to um
that is a very loose term
to say that it's fake the fact that um
so that's all i mean
i don't mean fake in any disparaging way
it's just we want to share this show to
it we're going to sell this show to
investors it's called the metaverse
we're talking about developing them yeah
nfts and they're all here just went up
by like 10 million
so i the the reason why i push back on
that is is because there is a there is a
cost associated well there may be
salaries first of all i love that they
were able to employ people but it's not
like fat cats like mike bithell money
bags mike that's getting made it's it's
the fact that there are hey we need for
the the game that we're trying to make
we're going to need to
grow and we're going to expand we're
going to need to add more animators
we're going to need to add more all of
these people and those people are making
something they're not carpenters that
are building a set but they're still
building something and there's a there's
a cost associated with that so while you
may be going to salaries
that's also going to
building tech building the machine yeah
building assets but that's the way that
you pay for that is through salaries
yeah
raw materials exactly i think that's my
point is like you're not just like
buying a physical thing unless it's an
engine
which in theory even that is often
salaried because somebody's made to
build it um i think there is something
into our latest game and give you a
percentage alarm yes thank you so much
the software is it's worth pointing out
100 doing this right now that's cool i
like this
the business model is super different
from films to games since studios with
since the big movie studios don't really
make movies anymore they're they're
distributors you know the movie right
they're just publishers yeah
yeah so the like every movie like every
every
feature film that i've been hired on
with almost no exceptions if when you
look at the paperwork of who i'm
technically making my deal with it's
usually
it like whatever the movie's name is you
know like like you know one shot el like
the movie llc or whatever they set up a
company that's a production company a
one-off
they raise the money it goes into the
accounts of that movie and then they pay
and and therefore every single person
who works on that film is a freelance
contractor there's no salaried employees
of of any kind so all the actors all the
set you know crew and camera operators
and the cinematographer and the lighting
people in the grip and the production
sound and the post sound and the
composer everybody has the razer hires
yeah they have rates whether it's day
rates or weekly rates or all-in deals or
you know points plus this blah blah
everybody negotiates what they are and
it's all bundled up with that one
company and and the the goal is
definitely not to make that company you
know
live on forever and ever in the way
until they rap yeah like well
specifically you don't want it to
because the whole point is liability and
tax right right yeah you're going to
close that entity the second you can so
you avoid whereas games games don't
really work like that at all that's what
i mean is like i feel like i have a very
good understanding of how it works in
film and less of an understanding of how
it works in games even though i've been
working in games today so i can answer
your question i literally just looked at
the budget for the the next big game
we're making great and it comes
everybody zoom in on mike's eyes see if
you can see the reflection
what is it there's no way my signal's
good enough
um
so it's uh yeah so for so we break it
down we obviously have like you know
a misc category which kind of covers
some of our expenses espresso machines
the main one is software servers cloud
stuff all of that stuff is in the
servers yes i haven't considered that
that's a that's a non-salaried
expense so those are kind of the
non-salaried expense and those are that
you know that number's in like the for a
project for a team like us that that's
tens of thousands of dollars you can
assume that for aaa that's in the
hundreds of thousands but yes compared
to like the overall budget for that
project it's about
about 2.5 percent of our overall
development budget is spent on the
software there's so there's some massive
caveats here that need to be considered
one is
um we all work from home so we're not
paying for office space which would be a
big cost
we're not paying for um that at all the
other thing is that the games industry
often builds so we're so the industry's
built around a concept called them
well most studios call them man months
we call them dev months because we're i
don't know pretentious um but man months
is the general term in the industry and
that is essentially how much it costs
women months
well that's why i call it that's why we
call them death months alana because
we're a different kind of studio and all
that because we're better but yeah no
it's
well i it's it's a weirdly outdated term
it is cut out
you could try to get it
in months yeah
horsepower too so when you're budgeting
so when you're like when you're like
budgeting a game or you're you know
asking someone for money or whatever
you're basically one of the first
questions a publisher will ask is what's
your man month like how and they mean
how much does that cost and the amount
of money is basically the burn rate
sorry
are they asking you that that's how much
you like months
how much one person for a month on
average at your company costs the mean
and that's from that so you can say oh
we've got a team of 20 people we're
working for five years you can do the
maths and you can work out no idea what
that is but what's crucial
so sms would probably be quite high for
the reason i'm about to say which is
that is the unit that we use as an
industry but that unit isn't just salary
we assume it's salary but actually that
you that that man month will factor in
salary it will factor in america will
factor in like garage health insurance
and [ __ ] like that that you guys have to
do it'll have like not over here because
we have socialized products
um
for healthcare
it's awesome i just i just pay my taxes
and then i can go to a hospital it's
brilliant
um
the uh the uh so it's it's it's their
salary it's their medical but it's also
their computer and it's also the it
support that they require and it's also
the software they use so as and then
crucially if you're a developer who is
being paid for by someone else and
that's most game studios work
essentially are paid by someone else in
the world
then also you're factoring in a little
bit of profit and you're factoring in a
bit of buff of when the publisher has a
ridiculous request that you have to kind
of change something or whatever so that
actually that number gets kind of slowly
inflated
so that also can lead to kind of a
misleading assumption so the the cost of
the so the budget i would say is
definitely
i would say on a game developed from
home in the way we do it at least 90
salaries
but there's a lot of kind of little
pockets of money that get kind of pulled
off in different directions so that
might not be quite
i would say i would say for us it's
probably about 90 salaries i imagine for
a bricks and mortar studio that's much
lower plus of course your man month has
to factor in your non-dev staff members
so your big game studios it's not the
it's not like everyone in the in the
building is working on the game right
there's
like things that i've never seen
anywhere i've ever worked we have um
i don't know what her actual title would
be but someone who's effectively a
building manager so like she she is
effectively entertaining manager yeah an
office manager kind of thing where like
she recently just did like a virtual
tour for the new hires who haven't been
to the office
um like so and we have also a lot i
think there's one person who just is
almost a community manager but only
internally
um so sms does a lot of really cool
stuff like
we have cooking classes that you can
take once a week there's yoga there's
like all of this like these extra
activities that i assume is one person's
job to organize like an internal
community manager to like a company
culture person i would think
and that's somebody that still factors
i
i don't know santa monica studios is uh
budgeting and leaving but they'd be
included in theory
well they'd be included but also i
imagine what they would do is when
they're you know explaining to uh the
bosses at sony worldwide and their
budgeting projects and stuff they would
still use a man month and that man month
will incorporate
you know that cooking class basically
every member of staff that's being
counted is it's you know is is one
percent of the man month that's being
asked for is covering that cooking class
right like those numbers all blend out
so yeah we're an industry that talks a
lot about salaries but i think that
buries a lot of
complexity i would like to point out
as a freelancer i am offered no cooking
class participation uh and that's
[ __ ] we'll jump on the zoom i'll
show you how to do an omelette sucks
in every one
every every single one he comes to all
of them
that's bastard
as a point of reference interestingly i
remember when the banner saga did its
kickstarter they asked for a hundred
thousand dollars because it was three
guys who had quit their jobs at bioware
in austin
and um and wanted to basically just have
the most basic money they were planning
on
living on their savings
um and just using that money to hire
some basic you know like animation
studio and things to help but but you
know arnie was going to be doing the art
john was the technical director alex was
the writer they had what they needed to
make the bones of the game and then just
the few disciplines but for example that
100k they were like arnie goes well look
i've opened garageband before i guess
i'll do the music like there was no
contingency plan but when the
kickstarter exploded and they ended up
raising about three quarters of a
million instead
they approached me and they approached
like a the kapow audio in australia to
do the um to do the sound design and
stuff and i remember one of the big
questions was
should we voice the game and now they
had been designing it
with um a pretty robust amount of
storytelling and so there's huge amounts
of dialogue and on-screen
choice pop-ups and stuff and
and and i remember they ran the numbers
at one point and they said
the given the lines the number of lines
that we have if we were to voice this
game it would basically be triple the
the current budget to add that feature
damn vo is crazy expensive
just especially given the sheer volume
and the fact that it's not like you just
blast through the lines one time it also
onboards an editorial cost it on boards
and i love it
so yeah what do you guys think of the
game of the year nominee yeah
troy's gonna troy is gonna point out
that it doesn't need to be expensive and
he's gonna have some good tips for
people who want to work out to do that i
i don't think that it has to be cost
prohibitive i think it will always be
expensive is a matter of perspective
right um for you you look at what a a
studio like
santa monica spends on toilet paper
compared to what bethel game spends on
toilet paper and they spin and that
their toilet paper is expensive we get
[ __ ] brilliant toilet what are you
talking about no there's no
situation i'm just saying it's like wow
that's a lot of money you guys spend on
someone's like well yeah we're a much
larger studio i know i'm an ass but i'm
a comfortable here we are
so i i think that the the the expense
scales and the the difference between
adding a voice to something that is just
text on screen it just opens up so many
things now you're having to do your your
local changes right you have to localize
so so now there's a whole other
additional cost it's not just like well
once we add actors in it's like once you
make the design choice to now
incorporate and and tell your narrative
through an actor
uh or even through voice it could be a
computer you know there's still even if
you just did that even if you just did
lambs there would still be
a pretty extensive amount of design that
that would you know uh also for
inherently charged for context that game
also has like 30 characters instead like
it's it's a huge cast of characters in
the banner saga so it wasn't just
you know a hero
on 15 of them though yeah 16. that's
true i could have stretched it right
like yeah yeah she got rid of jacob look
at the mafia had three in a little while
um the the other thing that like once
you start then going into performance
capture or or any kind of mocap to where
now we're capturing body data and we're
applying that to a model
um
you have to assume that there's going to
be
let's say you have a cast by that
sentence we're capturing body data and
we're applying it to a model i don't
know why
why is that weird i don't know why i
find that it sounds like a rap lyric
i'm not even gonna try again
i loved the wind up though
that was the good angel going um
one of the few things is not very good
at unless it was either going to be
it was either going to be eminem or not
appropriate so basically one of those
two things
um or more likely snow uh from
the rice yeah vanilla ice would have
been an upgrade um the the thing about
performance capture is is if you're
using for are you using face if you're
gonna do facial data now to incorporate
a company like faceware that's gonna be
able to take that data and process that
on that model
um you know i'm going to take your data
and put it on the model i can't i don't
even know it it's too weird it's too
abstract for me
um
but like
jokes that could be made right now it's
not good in a uh depending upon how like
how many cast members you have like do
you have just a a dude and a girl and
it's it's you know i just need a male
model and a female model which means i
need two rigs which a rig is basically
think like it think of it as like an
exoskeleton it is literally coco
huh
a roku bro why is it rope what's the
what's the one that people
what's the one with the sensors in it is
it rococo there's a specific anyway
don't worry about it please
specifically the whole ai theory
there's a mocap suit with sensors in it
i'm going to look it up move on and know
as one but that was like magnetic but
it's i think we should move on it's
it's not um
it's it has nothing to do with the suit
that you're using it has everything to
do with like hey this is the exoskeleton
of this character that we're going to
put this
our our character model on it's it's
literally the skeleton that moves it and
depending upon the height depending upon
the build depending upon is it human or
is it alien you have to you might have
to have a different rig that rig can
cost upwards of twenty thousand dollars
per rig so depending upon how many
characters you have it's a one-time
purchase and you could hopefully
duplicate that across multiple
characters but there's still going to be
potential if you have five characters
there could be a hundred grand you spend
just on that
then on average if you go to a
performance capture stage you could
anticipate not including actor payments
but just to walk onto that stage and
shoot you're looking at anywhere between
50 to 65 000 a day is that for renting
it
that is for walking on to that stage
that's not your own facility that is
going to the reserve or that's going to
digital dimension or digital domain even
uh on average you're going to spend 50
to 65 000 and that's going to be you're
already doing this but i was going to
say like say uh you give me a day of of
the last of us that you're shooting for
for performance purposes how many people
are required to be paid for that day to
exist
i mean people are required to be paid
for that day to exist yeah it's a weird
question but you get my favorite
questions like you have every actor
you've got a couple of operations how
many people are in that room
that need but that's not just that
because what happens because then
there's all the people afterwards that's
why i'm trying to restrict it a little
it's all of just on that day you could
have upwards of i was just on a shoot we
had about 40 people on set um um so
of which how many were actors
wild
troy was 20 of those 20 of those people
so you've got you've got your camera
department you have your sound
department you have your mocap
department you have your face department
you have your makeup department you have
you know multiple people that are doing
all of the jobs that are required
if you have a stunt coordinator uh like
we just did a shoot in london we had a
stunt quarter we had a stunt coordinator
and a stunned assistant we also who both
of them could double as stunt people
um but then you just have all of the the
people that that build your sets that
bring in your um uh props or or you know
are there to make sure that all the
markers are are in the right place it's
it takes a big team even on a small
shoot with two or three actors which is
what we had in london there were still
about 20 people on set
um
it is it is wild and and what you have
to then do
you look at it and go can we tell our
story in any other way do we have to
incorporate because if we if we don't
it's far less expensive
but you may not have as immersive of a
story you may not have as gripping of a
you know quote cinematic experience if
you don't have that but yeah you could
be spending on you know if you if you
were to amortize the cost of taking the
data and then quote solving it which
means it's super rough when they get it
it looks just like a bunch of you know
bees swarming around the body and then
they take it and go that marker right
there is his right clavicle and that's
it her elbow and that is her foot and
you solve that data to that rig
then that gets like a grayscale look
that has to go into the animation
pipeline is it the studios pipeline or
is it the
um the mocap studios pipeline and if
like you're a
let's say that mike bitly decides that
he wants to get into performance capture
he may not want to build
a animation pipeline that will support
you know being able to do a full
performance capture with the fidelity of
something even close to uncharted 4 or
last of us two
he may just want to outsource all of
that
even on a game uh like a shadow of war
we had our pipeline internal to monolith
there was another studio in canada that
was handling a whole section of the
cinematics that their pipeline was
handling and then there was the pipeline
at the studio that at the performance
capture still we're doing it and then
once you like
the beauty of
sony studios is they go all hands on
deck there's just like a hub of workers
that depend depending upon where studios
at are in their development they can
start recruiting from outside people so
it's not just people within sony santa
monica or naughty dog or insomniac or
whatever it's they're recruiting from a
bunch of people
um so it's super hard to say what is the
cost of doing performance capture but
essentially what you're saying is one
day can require
40 people
all of whom have to be experts in one
specific thing which means salaries come
with that
so yeah and that's why salaries are
still expensive
but if you look at it proportionately to
the people that will actually spend an
exorbitant and quote exorbitant amount
of money say upwards of
three to five million dollars just on
shooting their cinematics that will be a
smaller percentage of their budget
it shows you how non-linear it is though
that you know it's like a text-based
game you can find ways to kind of
gradually increase the cost by
longer development cycle or whatever but
then as soon as you crack the seal on
okay we need a lot of voice over and
voice performance and all that it
doesn't really expand linearly you kind
of just have this big upward thing and
then that can start to grow linearly but
then once you add performance capture
it's an even bigger sort of straight up
thing and it doesn't it doesn't budgets
don't really move along a straight line
in that way once you onboard that's what
creates that kind of gaps i'm talking
about of like the scale of the sort of
like strategy
because you can have a game that doesn't
have
uh any actual
actors like just text-based that can be
extremely emotional and impactful yeah
one hundred percent
career my whole my whole career is based
on the truth of that statement that's
true i was gonna say like me i mean also
have both done pretty well yeah yeah
you've got thomas you've got journey you
have inside you have all of this
um
the industry does fixate a little bit on
the idea that if we spend more money
then we'll we'll achieve greater art you
know if you look at a lot of levels like
on on lots of fronts like we definitely
equate triple a budgets with you know
with with better art um i apologize
i had the duck out i'll be right back
i'm not gonna i just have to go
downstairs back yeah
players don't players are smarter than
that but like there's definitely there's
always that weird conversation
especially around awards season of like
when you see aaa games like up for
awards in like
art direction directional story and
you're like
it is also a thing that seems the oscars
are always the same as well oh i was
gonna say it wasn't i was gonna say i
feel like it makes headlines when a
video game is really expensive but i
feel like i don't see as many headlines
when a movie is really expensive
that's because we grew out the tech
industry where that number was where it
was where is that thing it's also
insecurity so much of this i feel is
like the we're still as an industry
trying to convince our parents 100
percent that we're west hollywood
100 i'm so sick of it i'm so sick of it
hollywood we're cooler you talk to
hollywood people hollywood people
and you know what even like the suits in
hollywood think we're cooler on a lot of
levels like you talk to a lot of the
people working in that i did it
just the other day i was talking to
somebody who works pretty high up in
the entertainment or that side of the
entertainment industry and they were
talking about wanting to get a specific
ip for video games they were like we're
trying to buy this ip to make a game out
of it because it'd be incredible no
doubt and i was like disagree but i'm
not going to tell you that that wouldn't
work but it was like they were so like
convinced this is how you make money
video games we have to make a video game
that's how we're gonna make we're gonna
buy all these ips we're gonna make games
they have no no knowledge of how they're
going to do it
you've got to tell me this full story
off there because i want to hear i love
those people i find those people i mean
i can tell you that i don't mind telling
you that the ip because i'm not
revealing any connections to anything um
is that percy jackson was what they
wanted
they were like we're positive it's got
to be percy jackson and i was like oh
very two thousand i'm not sure about
that
i don't know but i didn't say jackson
that's what the kids love right
personally that was the logic the kids
love it it'll be the next minecraft it
was like not
not quite so fussy i just watched failed
the failed movie franchise first yes
i just watched the uh
recently i realized i had missed one of
those game rant screen rant uh pitch
meeting videos with the guy on oh he's
funny on the pitch it was the pitch for
the sequel to percy jackson and it
starts off with him saying like i've got
a great idea we're going to do a sequel
to percy jackson he goes oh yeah i kind
of remember that it was successful right
and he's like i guess anyway moving on
yeah
god he's so good
they really are i love him so much but
yeah you are right
like i feel like internally
a lot of the games industry wants to be
hollywood and it drives me nuts but then
hollywood's looking at us and being like
money
you have a lot of money right it's true
but a lot of that will be all like you
say the fact that we emphasize money you
know we focus on it yeah our industry we
focus on it so that's that creates it's
the same thing you see with the number
of people i have to explain nfts to now
on like a weekly basis because
everyone's seeing all the stories about
oh if you get into nfcs you're going to
make loads of money it's like you're
really not yeah okay um let me walk that
through for you for the record
also just to clarify when i mentioned
the when i said it's always like that at
the oscars what i specifically meant was
that um
it wasn't so much about budget but the
but the big blockbustery showy things
that just take a lot to get off the
ground they invariably get all the
sound design sound mix visual effects
type oscar and costumes
yeah it's like it's like a period drama
uh you know a jane austen adaptation is
all but guaranteed an oscar nomination
for costume because there's just this
baked in assumption on the part of
you know
like oh well they must that must have
been a big focus of their filmmaking
yeah you know that's a it's a period to
an extent fair enough right like i think
awards we we've talked about ceremonies
too much on this show but like the i i
do like awards awards are largely for
the culture rather than the individuals
so you know what if a bunch of people
loved a specific video game it should
get a bunch of awards that's awesome
like it's i'm not i'm not like knocking
it it's just there is a presumption that
if you don't have mocap or you don't
have high-res kind of characters or you
don't have this or you don't have that
you can't tell a story and and i hear
all those arguments because people
always reply to them with thomas was
alone so i see it in my feed every
single day yeah because there are there
are these games thomas was alone joe i
mean i i understand
journey was actually all troy as
performance capture on the on the right
just
there's a brilliant there's a brilliant
video i made with a mocap studio have
you seen that like we did an april days
of april fool's day video with the guy
he's like the mocap guy for iron man
it's like him in a box with mocap
sensors and we synced it all up to the
footage you know that that's cool i do
have a question if i may interject
because
mike you seem like you are like you're
vehemently opposed to doing any kind of
performance capture
why not if it's oh okay that's really
expensive because it's really expensive
i'm not against it i it's for the exact
reason you're saying is like for the
numbers that come up when you look at
doing it in the kind of professionalized
context you're talking about so a proper
studio with triple team and all that the
numbers are so high that
the scale of game i would have to make
so that that wasn't a ridiculous
proportion of our budget right we as a
studio are not kind of set up to make
those kind of scale of games so it
wouldn't makes we'd be making a game
where it was like
you know a
quarter of the budget was spent on
performance capture which is ridiculous
unless you're making a quantic dream
game right like unless you're making
something where that is the focus
um this doesn't make sense what does
appeal to me is stuff like and i looked
it up it is rococo where it is these
kind of personal suits where you can do
it much more ad hoc and there's some
interesting stuff being done with that
that gear i've seen there are other
indies who are doing mocap but they're
doing it in their living room with
essentially by strapping wii remotes to
themselves and getting into it i
by the way this is there's gonna be so
many people that just do not like this
statement but
i am for this this industry moving
forward
it doesn't have to bend to my will nor
does it have to
um appeal to my sensibilities nor did
has to agree with my
principles it doesn't i want this i
believe in this industry as a whole and
that means if it takes like
what
but i'm not vehemently against it okay
that's fair because i want great work
done in the field i just can't afford it
because i do think that at some point
it's like that's not a bethel game
right
you you would have to well nobody in
when we were working on journey you know
tgc was off coming off of flower and
before that flow and i remember
this didn't last long but there was a
brief conversation about midway through
when i started talking about scheduling
orchestra sessions um where they go
would a live orchestra kind of
pull us out of our indie street cred
you know were the hip kids that made
flower
disrupter types does it kind of
mainstreamize us are we are we playing
with house money now like there was
there was a little bit it didn't last
long because i was like guys you know
just listen to the difference like just
i'm sorry do you want it to be good or
do you want to cling to this very odd
sense of what's hip uh what an
interesting
uh
stigma to be up against i i totally get
that but that's when you when you ask
like would performance capture suddenly
take away
the biffle-ness it would chip away at
the bittleness potentially
i i i i mean for a start we don't have
any indie street cred as a studio like
we are like we're not in that kind of
indie clip you're not lucas polk you're
not yeah we're not that kind of student
i've made my piece with that no it's
it's that that we're that's not who
that's not who we are zero so i don't
think there is necessarily i think
people just want us to make good games
ultimately the i think the reality is um
and this is something i have to think
about a lot across all fields of gay
i've literally had
a conversation with someone about this
today at length it was an hour and a
half long meeting on this exact subject
is
at my scale it's all about if the most
important thing is what the player sees
whatever's in front of the player like
how it's achieved ultimately doesn't
matter like it doesn't matter how
beautiful the back of a painting is when
you hang on the wall like it's it's it
you know
steve jobs famously made sure the
insides of his computers looked
brilliant because he was crazy um that's
fine but like ultimately in my opinion
like it's about putting you want to put
the value and the money where where the
audience is going to see it and that's
ultimately the best value i think the
reality is to the average player
they don't notice that our games don't
have mocap in like i think and
ironically a lot of them do but they
have off-the-shelf mocap volume is i
still point to that with the team a
little bit because that game's entire
animation i think minus two or three
special cases and a cutscene
the gameplay animation is all off the
shelf mocap data we bought for about a
hundred dollars i didn't know you could
do that um sure
it's better
you can now and i do
go on websites which have thousands of
free troy doesn't like this i'm sorry i
just disagree with it it's like you
can't say it's better you you could say
it's just something that is no longer
i'm not saying it's better than any i'm
saying it's i'm saying it's better than
a hundred dollars i'm saying now it's
free that's better i'm not saying it's
better than an actual performance from
an actor for a role
but you can do that seriously
yeah
some of them are not and that's
definitely not what i'm saying like to
be clear like but in there are there are
unless you unless your game is
benefiting from troy's performance right
in a mocap suit
then if if if the player doesn't notice
troy's performance because it's a
character that big absolutely away from
the camera you're what then it's you
know kept the grenades
conquered it's like it's ego it's like
if austin went to abbey road to record
someone playing a flute
and it's like well you could have
recorded this great
like otherwise it's ego right you're
going in there because you want to say
i'm going to step on you austin because
i would love to throw in something i
think you may
point to
depending on who the flautist is i said
flautist
they don't play the flat they're a
flutist is it a flutist
and they do play the flute
floutis plays the flute i flew to this
face i thought it was called a flautist
anyway it is but that's stupid i agree
but i i'm still trying to play by the
way i see composer takes so austin's
excited by where the music industry can
go troy
i'm not a pianist i'm holding a pianist
so if i told you is like hey we're gonna
record this i think you're a pianist
man we're gonna record this this flutist
at abbey road you're like uh pretentious
how dare you just spending money because
you can you're like okay well hold on
this this flutist is local to london
and even though we're based in the
states it could be
far more expensive to record at any
studio in the states
so everything is contextualized
situation
it is contextualized and in that
specific context where it made sense yes
of course it would make sense but
that's what i'm saying there is no
standard you can't you can't standardize
the way that games are made because
everyone is different yeah every studio
i'm not trying to i'm not i'm not trying
to but i'm saying that people should
it's a bigger argument though
standardizing sorry it's a it's a much
bigger argument though when you start
talking about standardizing games
what did i say no no i feel like i'm
saying it like i didn't mention
standardization at all i'm just saying
no you didn't did you okay carry on
sorry argue the
argue my own point no i
it is it is specific but my point is i
think to answer your question completely
honestly the reason i don't do mocap is
because for the money it costs my
players would notice that i'd done it
um and that's because of the kind of
games that you make bingo because the
kind of games we make but also because
our games do have so for example
subsurface circular is a game about a
bunch of robots sat on a pla on a train
talking to each other and they're kind
of being shook around by the train
um i paid an animator to make me a bunch
of one-frame poses of the robot sat in
various positions all the motion in that
game is me using essentially some very
rudimentary physics just to bounce them
around a bit as with the movement of the
train and i've seen people in reviews
talk about how weirdly good the
animation is for such a simple game it's
that kind of thing where like that's a
path that was a job that took me an
afternoon and created the illusion that
we'd actually like done very expensive
animation in that in that place we'd
have a lot of trouble with the network
because we're trying to make something
that looks realistic
for everything are you i don't know i'm
not using makeup for like your core
gameplay i assume you're doing a lot of
if you are using mocap as a starting
point you're still doing a lot of
keyframe to make it work yeah there are
definitely also keyframes yes
but it is it has gotten to the point
where it's like hey we need you to i did
an entire day they called it dance cards
and it's an entire day where you go i
need you to walk here i need you to walk
out of 45 i want you to walk in a 90 and
you need to walk out of 135 so it's
because what they don't want there to be
is for someone to use stock animation
for my character walking and then all of
a sudden i walk in
most people you're right will never be
able to go they use stock animation they
probably went to stockanimation.com and
bought that you know 8.99 bundle for
that they're just gonna feel it and
that's well that's we so we have a word
for that which is the fancy sofa you're
the fancy sofa in that if you're if you
have an apartment and you've you know
you've not got much money you're you've
filled it with like the cheapest [ __ ]
you can find like all of us did our
first apartment but yeah for whatever
you have like a really wealthy uncle and
they're like i'm going to get you the
best chair in my fancy so far
extravagant i'm really excited about it
hell yeah dude that's awesome and i'm
sure your place is beautifully decorated
this is not a criticism of you no
everything else is like when you're
right
if you put if you put a luxurious
antique sofa in the middle of an
apartment which is decked out in like
standard kind of cheap stuff the cheap
stuff will look cheaper because now
you've got that fancy sofa that's what
you're describing troy is my stock mocap
data doesn't look bad until i put the
fancy sofa that is troy in a cutscene
because now suddenly there's that
disjoint you can kind of you can shine
say if if you took a a a standard stock
london flat new york apartment whatever
that was just a studio apartment brick
walls
and you left it bare floor and and bare
walls or maybe you put up a painting or
whatever and a lamp and you put a really
really nice piece of furniture it
elevates the room
it doesn't it you don't all of a sudden
realize the discrepancies between like
oh that's not really the best brick
there's the idea of us getting really
hard into interior design here
here's how
the thing is you're absolutely right
like it's you're absolutely right your
metaphor holds as well i would argue if
that sofa was wonderful and expensive
and then you turned around and then you
turned back and it was a
[ __ ] plank of wood on two breeze blocks
for sure and then you look back right
like if somebody breaks my metaphor
doesn't completely hold what if you're
like you can't put good next to awful
and but it would be noticeable i like
the problem if you sell down to dinner
with somebody well i just i think i can
make a better analogy
if you sat down to dinner with somebody
and in in that same really like low rent
apartment there's no frills anywhere
there's water stains you know and it's
everything feels like it's crumbling
apart and you're eating off of an old
card table you found on the street but
they serve you dinner with like thousand
dollar plates that's different it would
feel it would but it would it would
actually make you more aware of the rest
and for me it would be like
this is like i would immediately have
questions i would immediately okay
that's something fortunate
that's my point is you are
disproportionately better than a stock
animation however i can think that yes
um but i do believe it's like all we can
do is this all we can do in this but
we're choosing to spend
our money in this because we believe
this will elevate perfect example is the
shoot that we just did
small cast we came in
um the story is simple the the game
mechanics are um nothing that are like
holy crap they're just really really
they're they're well done but they're
simple
um we know what they knew what kind of
game we're making we knew what kind of
game we're walking into and he was like
here's what i really need this is really
about can i get you to care about these
three people in order to do that i
really need good performances out of
people so we got three great actors
together and we workshopped those scenes
and we elevated them what really
elevated was getting there on the day
and going here's some couple of fight
sequences that we need we really need to
spend the money on a stunt coordinator
and a fight choreographer to come in
and turn these really really simple
moments just like oh no this is just the
scene where he does the thing into these
big set pieces that we did on the stage
so i that to me is a fancy sofa like you
you brought in a fancy sofa to this
no that's a nice throw over the fancy
sofa is my point in terms of skype i
can't keep up with your metaphor your
metaphor
12 minutes
i guess
i
yes 12 minutes 12 minutes is a fantastic
there could have been anybody there are
parts that are mocapped
um
even outside of the actors obviously
there are parts that are mocapped where
they kiss at the start of the loop it's
mocap that they hug each other but then
there are stiff animations for when they
like walk away from each other so will
they jerk between yeah or they just like
like their interruptions that that that
makes the
inclusion of the smooth mocap
seem out of place as opposed to
elevating it i got you no one thinks
that playing like uh
you you've never thought about the
quality of the animation among us or in
the animation in like
most indie games it's because that thing
is very elevated when that mocap thing
works it's beautiful sure and what do i
see in all the reviews of of 12 of 12
minutes is
the animation sucks and the animation
sucks because some of it's really
[ __ ] good but they made it makes an
issue it lacks cohesion because it has
two different styles it feels weirder
that some of it's really good and some
of it's not
another example is advanced warfare
assistance you got kevin spacey you got
his likeness and you spent so much time
on the fidelity especially for that time
to be
holy crap
it was it was one to one
but then you go literally talking about
turning to the left and going out of
that cinematic you're like ah [ __ ] all
of you look terrible because there was
such a discrepancy between the game
model i would much rather that's like
that
jeff goldblum there that was amazing
i remember that feeling so strongly in
the uh
in the 90s when like the star wars um
jedi knight or dark forces 2
had all the fmv cut scenes where you'd
like a dark jedi would come out and it
was clearly an actor shot on a green
screen and then the cut scene would end
and this incredibly low poly version of
them would be in that position in on the
screen and it was just like ah this
horror even then
as future tech as they were hoping to
convince us the fmv was it just showed
how far we had to come yeah and and
actually it's funny i was wanting to
interject and ask a peripheral question
and you you teed it up amazingly
troy of um because i just finished
playing
the campaign of call of duty vanguard
and oh i can't wait it's really fun it's
they never they never they never fail to
impress with the the the set piece kind
of like spectacles it's just a pretty
astounding amount of craziness that they
can they can jam in
but it's interesting because
um
we're so accustomed to
this art form of acting in games
especially performance capture being the
kind of thing where
the gulf between who the character is
and the actor
is can be as wide as the imagination
whereas a film a person appearing on
camera other than occasionally obviously
elaborate prosthetic makeups and things
like that generally speaking you know oh
it's look it's dicaprio playing such and
such and so the result of which is um i
found i i couldn't decide if i was on
board with
laura bailey's likeness being so spot on
because i was like i feel like i've been
trained to expect
something different for the last few
decades and it's so
noticeably her and dominic monaghan is
also in the cast and it was like
that's that's a hobbit uh and like it it
was
it was a fascinating thing i hadn't
found myself thinking about much because
you know obviously the characters that
you're most associated with are not your
facial likeness right and and i just
found myself going is that
are we moving in that direction that's
going to be the norm more and more that
it's it's them as them or or do we lean
into the fact that it doesn't have to be
there this is i this is one of the
reasons why i love this industry is i
i've talked about to be clear laura is
very good
she's fantastic she's she's always good
she's all she's basically um she's
basically jude law's character in enemy
at the gates uh you know the russian
sniper sold i love that movie i
i have a wonderful team and um
headed up by my agent natanya and who
for service was also a sniper at
stalingrad
that's so weird
um
i'm convinced his agent is fomke
janssen's character from goldeneye
we have these conversations a lot where
it's like hey we want to do this project
and it's it may be something that is we
haven't done before or it's a character
we haven't done before it's a studio we
haven't worked with there's something
novel about it or something that's
compelling beyond just the paycheck
um
the
the one question that they have or that
that is has become a factor now is
likeness and it's like man we're already
trying to make sure that you know
you're hearing somebody drill by the way
um
the
yep
uh
get ready guys it's fun owning a home
really really good
they're they're
sorry oh my god they're fixing it
um
the
man my atd is going crazy right now
the ability to add into a component of
of a likeness to where it's
already me
it's something that i've had to
you know fight against because people
are like he's in every game it's like
well there's a whole other layer that we
have to take away if it's going to be my
face
so i i'm very cognizant of that and
there may be times just like yeah we
want it to be my face like death
stranding it's like we want it's going
to be everybody else it would be weird
if it wasn't me
but let's not make that the and this
other game that we just did it was like
let's not make it me so that it doesn't
have to be
um
[Music]
it does have to be me in that game and
maybe people people can just see the
character that's something that this
specific industry affords me that you
know not every
not everyone else gets so
you might be able to watch less if you
have to
have your likeness right and everything
but that exactly that's why
they're negotiated separately as well so
there's actually weirdly a weird strange
incentive for you to keep your face as
like a limited asset right like if your
face is in everything that that lowers
its value in a way like from a financial
point of view so even if i
because you negotiate separately for a
facial like this if i wanted troy in my
game to do voice
and or i wanted to do voice and have his
face in there i would be expected to pay
more
there would be a separate conversation
yeah even i have some really interesting
likeness stuff sometimes if i do like a
brand deal or any like influencer stuff
where they'll be like and
we want likeness and i'm always like
whatever and my manager is always like
absolutely not um it doesn't mean
anything to me but i guess on paper if i
do a brand deal with a certain company
and they ask to be able to like use my
image then they can use it for the rest
of time on whatever they want and i
would not have known that without him
that i'm like whatever you could post a
picture of me on your website i don't
give a [ __ ] that's fine he's like no no
no no no no no no no it's another
negotiation point right if they want
like that's he just works as nice
okay but if they want it then they pay
for it so you couldn't go you could if
you chose to if you want if you wanted
that you could negotiate you know and
that could become part of negotiation
either you pay more or you get a
different kind of
rights than you'd expect or whatever
like yeah yeah yeah it's a weird one
but i i certainly run into that
conversation before with because we got
games with likenesses you know ian and
lance are both in
uh john wayne you literally have my face
your fate your literal face you
literally have me
well in cyberpunk it's very serious i
will use that face in every single work
i'll wrap that to models you'll you'll
be seeing a lot i don't know what i'm
saying
whatever you want
i don't know what's going on with troy
he's moving his desk he's got a dude
i started looking i was like my desk is
going askew and it was the one side and
now it's the other literally i'm
watching as it just goes like this
i look like i'm in a villain's later in
66 batman was it like your standing
desks like the pressure it's nice but
for some reason it's doing that so i'm
like this and i have computers and [ __ ]
on this my ps5 is on that side it's just
[ __ ] i gotta go anywhere
i also have to run you going back to
london again
yeah oh my god so i'll be nice anytime
you watch this we saw each other
mike i know it was great that was a good
one
when are you in london
uh i will be there we can arrange this
offline yeah the audience
should be a lot of fun maybe that'd be
super fun we can continue this and kind
of like wait a minute why don't you not
like actors mike bethel
damn it for the records i like i like
actors i love troy they just don't offer
anything that you can't be offered by 99
cent stocks yeah animation that is not
what i said and i encourage listeners to
go back i encourage mike and all the
best to save that money and put it into
the music budget alana will you do the
thank you to play with us and everybody
i'm a little piece i'm a video game
writer that's my fifth please video game
director that's true casey video game
actor that's awesome
he's a video game composer we will see
you guys next week
bye